j'ai le ventre qui gargouille à temps
d'écouter étrangers vous savez des fois
je tombe sur des histoires incroyables
que j'ai ensuite envie de raconter en
vidéo j'avais raconté l'été dernier
l'histoire de anne van migraine je vous
invite à aller la voir
l'histoire est assez incroyable et
ensuite y avait eu évidemment celle de
ojai fierté nationale il a plus percée
que david guetta et dj snake réunis et
flaubert m'envoyer une photo il était
dans un magasin d'une figurine de andry
je sais pas pourquoi mes mails envoyés
d'ailleurs samedi soir vous avez
beaucoup touché il ya pas mal de gens
qui m'ont parlé de cette vidéo donc
voilà je suis content on a rendu un bel
hommage à entrer aujourd'hui nouvelle
histoire et elle est tout aussi
fascinante
connaissez-vous djassin sur humiliant
que je dirais non
masculins bien sûr que nous fait pas
toujours ce qu'on dit oui vous êtes une
prof d'histoire ce prof d'histoire pause
avant de passer à l'incroyable histoire
de jasper masculine je vous invite
d'abord à découvrir l'histoire de martin
bonjour les étudiants aujourd'hui nous
allons parler économie genre comme les
bons de réductions au supermarché nos
martin c'est complètement con comme
remarque ans j'aurais pas aimé il n'y
connaît rien aux économies moi j'ai
plein de bons plans d'accord tu veux dix
euros ou et vas-y et bien grâce à mon
lien en descriptions tu recevras 10
euros au lieu de 3 euros en inscrivant à
igraal mais purée de quoi tu parles mec
tu ne connais pas igraal non mais je
suppose que tu vas mais graal est un
site une app est une extension gratuite
et sécurisée de cashback qui rembourse
une partie de tes achats sur internet
à chaque commande chez plus de 1700
marchands partenaires toutes catégories
confondues
monsieur martin est en train de me faire
un placement de produit martin je t'en
prie partage donc tombons plomb avec le
reste de la classe
d'abord tu dois te rendre sur un site
partenaire l'extension détecte les
marchands partenaires directement depuis
ton moteur de recherche
une fois sur le site il te suffit
d'activer le cash back depuis
l'extension c'est tout maintenant il ne
te reste plus qu'à passer sa commande à
chaque achat en ligne vous cumulé des
gains cash back dans votre cagnotte
igraal des 20 euros acquis dans la
cagnotte
vous pouvez demander un virement
bancaire virement paypal ou chèques
cadeaux et comment ça fonctionne i gr
elle touche une commission des marchands
qu'il redistribue aux nombres c'est ce
qui permet le cash back
maintenant tu peux nous expliquer le
rapport avec mon cours le cash back est
cumulable avec les codes promo marchand
qui gras elle diffuse et les soldes ça
fait donc de sacrées économies
en effet je te mets vin sur vin pour ce
bon plan c'est une blague
je te rappelle que tu as 10 euros avec
mon lien cousine je suis pas ta cousine
super rendez vous en descriptions voir
merci martin pour cette intervention se
terrent croyable on peut applaudir quand
même s'il vous plaît merci je
connaissais pas du tout pour être
honnête je suis tombé sur des articles a
pas très longtemps qui parlait de son
histoire j'ai trouvé ça assez fascinant
et j'ai donc décidé de vous la raconter
aujourd'hui sachez que son histoire est
tellement ouf qu'il ya un film prévue
sur lui un film à gros budget à
hollywood avec mme acteurs
doctor strange j'ai oublié son nom c'est
impoli vous au moins vous avez vous avez
compris au moins bref jasper masculine
il est né en 1902 et il a un gros passif
papa et papy sont de très grands
magiciens d'accord mais vraiment de très
grands magiciens genre le nom masculine
à cette époque là tout le monde le
connaît et j'espère son grand père c'est
d'ailleurs celui qui a créé vous savez
la machine l'espèce de voyante robot la
kiffer bas des équipes qui tirent des
cartes là peut-être vous l'avez déjà vu
si vous avez comme moi fait plusieurs
musées comme il était petit de magie ou
de l'illusion moi j'étais très fan de ça
quand j'étais petit j'ai acheté les
quitter tout et je faisais des tours aux
anniversaires de mes potes
bref j'espère devient à son tour
illusionniste magicien et il a une
petite pression quand même c'est que
papy et papa ils ont bien dit qe2 game
il va donc créer quelques tours à lui
grâce auquel il va pouvoir remplir des
salles de spectacles et son tour le plus
connu c'est un tour dans lequel justin
l'aval des lames de rasoir
bref il est en train de se faire
connaître il fait honneur un petit peu à
son nom de famille est là au delà cette
chambre ou bien on les gars m'avaient
steffi graf du bruit ça doit être super
chiant la famille masculine ayant fait
fortune que grâce au spectacle se voit
profondément affectée par la seconde
guerre mondiale ils sont ruinés à tel
point qu'ils doivent vendre leur salle
de spectacle mais jasper le petit
dernier 37 ans il se laisse pas abattre
lui se dit met à tanguer une guerre
mondiale là une 2e mais c'est une
excellente opportunité pour me faire
connaître c'est facile de percer en tant
qu illusionniste cognac guerre mondiale
non pas du tout qu'est ce qui t'arrive
j'espère tu vas faire quoi tu vas aller
au front sortir un lapin du chapeau et
tu prends les allemands ils vont rendre
les armes enfin je comprends pas en
septembre 1939 il se fait enrôler dans
l'armée
mais comme il a 37 ans et qu'il est
magicien il va être envoyé dans une
équipe qui doit être formée à l'art du
camouflage dans cette équipe il ya
surtout plein d'artistes il ya un
zoologiste aussi eia jasper magicien on
dirait une troupe de cirque voilà qu'on
soit honnête savoir qu'à cette époque
y'a pas genre de satellites ya pas de
lunettes thermiques
bref y'a pas les moyens de technologie
qu'on a aujourd'hui et encore plus dans
ce qui est de repérer l'ennemi à
l'époque les mutuelles repères avec tes
yeux donc soit on voit des hommes en
avions repéré depuis le ciel ou en pot
fast mon pote et probablement 30 cette
autre manière de faire du repérage mais
je ne suis pas prof d'histoire et vous
n'êtes pas premier ministre
bref masculine et les enrôler dans cette
unité et sa formation commence deux mois
plus tard un inspecteur général visite
le camp jasper ça fait un moment qu'ils
bossent sur un moyen de cacher les
bunkers vous savez dans lesquels on a
juste une mitrailleuse qui dépasse et
d'en créer des faux en guise de leurs
l'inspecteur tombe là dessus il trouve
sa remarquable et l'envoie jasper et son
équipe au caire en egypte la balle
équipe elle a un rôle précis c'est
protéger les soldats anglais en les
camouflant et met au point des
subterfuges
brain les soldats allemands mais ils
n'ont pas été envoyées là sans raison
c'est que la situation elle est un peu
critique les navires sens et ravitailler
les troupes se font systématiquement
abattre par des bombardiers allemands et
c'est relou parce que le canal de suez
c'est un point très stratégique puisque
c'est la principale route commerciale du
pétrole qui on va pas se mentir permet
de faire voler les avions alimenter les
tanks générer de l'énergie experts
externes donc si les allemands prennent
le contrôle du canal il n'y a plus de
pétrole pour les alliés c'est bon jasper
il est convaincu qu'il a un rôle
important à jouer là dedans sauf que peu
de temps après son arrivée il se fait un
petit causse c'est à dire ils passent de
devoir mettre au point des subterfuges
impressionnant à faire des tours de
magie aux soldats pour les divertir et
leur remonter le moral c'est bien mais
il n'a pas signé pour ça après un moment
il va négocier avec ses supérieurs il va
leur dire écoutez les gars voilà j'ai
remonter un peu le moral des troupes
j'ai refait le tour de magie ça les
amuse de lapin dans le chapeau tout ça
je suis désolé ce tour me traumatise je
trouve ça tellement bizarre je suis
désolé à tous ceux qui regardent cette
vidéo qui font apparaître des lapins
dans des chapeaux je voulais pas vous
blesser
bref je disais il va négocier avec ses
supérieurs et va être autorisée à créer
sa propre section spécialisée dans le
camouflage qui va appeler the magic
geng il s'est cru de vache au nez cet
enfant et recrutent des dessinateurs des
ingénieurs en électrique des chimistes
des charpentiers bref que des mecs qui
ont le profil pour l'aider à mettre au
point des subterfuges quelques mois plus
tard il fait face à sa première vraie
mission des soldats de l'armée anglaise
attendre un navire de ravitaillement
très important le navire doit décharger
sa cargaison au port d'alexandrie
mais l'armée anglaise doivent se
démerder pour trouver un moyen de faire
diversion et de forcer les avions
allemands a bombardé ailleurs que sur le
bateau sens et les ravitailler et sur le
port d'alexandrie la masculine il est
chaud il sort un 8-2 coeur et il a une
idée on va créer à quelques kilomètres
d'ici
infos port d'alexandrie ya 0 vannes son
projet c'est de faire disparaître le
vrai port d'alexandrie et d'en
construire un faux qui se ferait
bombardé à la place du vrai alors
évidemment ils vont pas le construire en
taille réelle parce que c'est impossible
et vont pas non plus construire avec les
vrais matériaux ils vont tout faire en
carton et à une échelle plus petite mais
ils vont utiliser des tricks de
perspectives de manière à brain les
pilotes allemands et que vu du ciel
y'a pas une grosse différence entre le
faux et le vrai port pour que ça
paraisse réalistes ils vont quand même
mettre des lumières partout dans l'oeuf
au port et ils vont aussi enterrer des
charges d'explosif et ça c'est méga mall
le jour j arrive et suivent le plan déjà
ils éteignent les lumières
du vrai port d'alexandrie il est donc
plongé dans l'obscurité et il allume les
lumières du faux port d'alexandrie les
avions allemands arrivent et les anglais
déclenché les charges explosives
enterrés dans le sol du faux port
d'alexandrie
du coup les avions allemands il voit des
explosions et il pense que c'est juste
l'assaut qui a commencé et que les
premiers avions déjà lâché leurs bons
ils vont donc tous en direction du faux
port pour le survoler et y lâcher leurs
bons et ça va durer trois nuits pendant
ce temps là les anglais et réceptionne
la cargaison du navire de ravitaillement
ils sont refaits et suite au succès de
l'opération jasper est promu et ses
techniques d'illusions se répandent peu
à peu dans les armées ali ben bongo je
ferme ma gueule pardon pour les blagues
sur le magicien pardon il va axer sa
stratégie sur le fait non pas de cacher
le canal de suez mais de le rendre très
difficile à repérer depuis le ciel le
installe donc 20 machines tout au long
du canal de suez constitué d'un
projecteurs surpuissants et de tout un
système de jeu de miroirs visant à
rendre la lumière émise par le
projecteur encore plus puissante la
mission est réussie
les avions qui survolent le canal de
suez ne voit absolument rien qui sont
aveuglés et une nouvelle fois jasper est
un sacré bg il est envoyé auprès du
général montgomery pour l'aider à battre
romaine le général a déjà un plan il
veut attaquer son rival par le nord tout
en simulant une attaque par le sud
jasper et son équipe réfléchissent et là
ils ont une idée assez ouf je me douche
la barbichette puisque c'est malin il se
dit bon tous les temps qui seront au
nord et dans le sud
ils veulent faire une fausse attaque
mais il en voit très peu d'hommes et ils
ont voit pas de temps qu'ils envoient
des camions c'est un peu cramé donc ce
qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va déguisés
les camions en tant qu et les véhicules
de la vraie attaque dans nord les tanks
eux on va les grimé en camion on inverse
complètement le truc bas les mecs ils
l'ont fait [ __ ] de fait ils sont même
allés jusqu'à faire des fausses traces
de chenilles dans le sud derrière les
tanks en bois et à faire aussi plein de
fausses transmission radio avec du faux
bruits de fond comme s'il y avait
vraiment un monde plein de bruit moteur
plein de trucs bilan le général
montgomery gagnent la bataille
jasper est un boss en vrai c'est chaud
de trouver son utilité en pleine seconde
guerre mondiale quand tu es magicien
illusionniste fin c'est pas évident de
dire que tu es tricks vont vraiment
berné une armée entière et demi quand
j'ai lu tout ça je vais être honnête
j'étais émerveillé j'ai commandé de
nouveaux un petit coffret de magie là
comme quand j'étais petit maintenant je
vous dis un truc qui va vous briser le
coeur comme il a brisé le mien tout ce
que je viens de vous raconter c'est la
version des faits de jasper masculin
alors qu'en fait il se pourrait qu'elle
ne correspond pas totalement à la
réalité pas tout
allemand déjà on sait que c'est sa
version des faits à lui puisque il à
raconter tout ça dans un livre qui est
sorti en 1949 d'ailleurs ce livre serait
sorti sous son nom à lui sauf qu'il
l'aurait fait ghost et c'est à dire
qu'il aurait en réalité fait écrire par
quelqu'un d'autre que lui vous voulez un
spin off un film entier sur la magics
quan elle n'a jamais existé excusez moi
je vous inflige la même peine à la même
frustration que moi j'ai eu en enquêtant
sur ce gars en fait j'espère il aurait
bossé dans une unité qui s'appelait la
et fort ce qui a été créé par le général
archibald wives et dans cette unité
jasper bosser aux côtés du brigadier
d'aude les clark qui lui était
apparemment un mec vraiment chaud au
camouflage
bref cette unité elles avaient été
montées surtout pour aider à la
libération des prisonniers anglais et
donc on y recruter beaucoup d'
illusionniste et magicien parce que le
but c'était de réussir à envoyer aux
prisonniers des trucs pouvant les aider
à se libérer des cartes des couteaux ce
genre de trucs une chose est sûre les
véhicules déguisé en tant que ça a
vraiment eu lieu c'était l'opération
bertram
sauf que l'opération bertram c'est pas
du tout j'espère qu'il a créé c'est le
général wolfe
tout ça ne serait donc pas l'initiative
de masculine mais par contre il aurait
permis effectivement de réaliser
l'opération aux côtés des autres membres
de cette unité dont il ya un peu de vrai
un peu de fausses et c'est terrible
autre chose jasper serait resté que un
an dans la r force avant d'être envoyés
pendant trois ans dans la section
bien-être section dans laquelle il
aurait passé les trois ans de guerre
restants et ce qui faisait ses des tours
de magie et des tricks d'illusions
auprès des soldats pour leur remonter le
moral
bref son livre il l'a écrit du coup
après la guerre et la publier en 49
mais gros bide tout le monde s'en bat
les couilles du coup il décide de
changer de vie et il va s'installer en
afrique du sud où il va être moniteur de
conduite rien à voir mais du coup d'où
vient de mythes pourquoi ans raconte
autant de trucs à son sujet est ce que
c'est une des légendes du coup
uniquement ou est ce qu'il ya une part
de vrai et de faux en fait vingt ans
après sa mort dans les années 80 un
livre sort et fait un carton
ce livre c'est the war magicien écrit
par david fisher et c'est un livre qui
raconte l'histoire vraie d'un magicien
qui durant la seconde guerre mondiale
aider l'armée anglaise
à tel point qu'il aurait même était le
responsable du triomphe de certaines
batailles
ça me rappelle quelque chose david
fisher lui il a encore plus romancée
exagérer les choses dans une foire
magicienne par exemple jasper il est
décrit comme le chef de son unité
il n'a jamais été chef de son unité il
est dit qu'il aurait aussi apparemment
participé à des réunions de la plus
haute importance notamment pour mettre
en place l'opération bertram sauf que
depuis les registres ont été
déclassifiés et rien dans les registres
ne mentionne son nom quand il s'agit de
réunions importantes à ce sujet là bref
aujourd'hui on sait que jasper a rejoint
l'armée et à aider d'une manière ou
d'une autre à camoufler des trucs mais
comme des milliers d'autres gens on sait
pas à quel point il a été important mais
plein de gens connaissent son nom est
plein de gens pensent que c'est vraiment
un héros de la guerre alors que dans les
traces écrites
rien ne le prouve charlatans pas
charlatans on sait pas bref ça vous
intéresse fait des recherches documentez
vous sur ce sujet vous allez voir c'est
vraiment intéressant en tout cas je suis
content d'avoir la cote et son histoire
j'espère que vous a plu j'ai hâte de
voir le film faites nous rêver hollywood
merde je vous dis à bientôt c'est pas
souvent qu'on fait des vidéos comme ça
où je raconte l'histoire de quelqu'un
mais là je trouve que ça valait le coup
à l'ailé squeeze hausse les petits
squeeze aussi vous allez vous habituer à
ce petit surnom bisous
[Musique]